hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to quadrant now I can't
move my left mouse all right I can't
look at all now
what the Frick sorry alright my cabin
okay I'm moving with the mouse
I can't look around there we go okay
we're back okay we're back in business
all right so bad things have happened
but we now saw the monster but the
monster kinda went away after we were
doing a thing um this doesn't seem good
herb oh [ __ ]
okay I'm assuming I can go when it
doesn't do the thing okay maybe not okay
we're Padova Dibby Dibby Dibby Dibby BAM
whoo all right okay here we go here we
go okay I think we're good okay I wonder
what horrible monstrosity awaits me down
here okay that horrible monstrosity hi
hi horrible monstrosity how you doing I
saw your big bro I know they were saying
that you guys were so intelligent but uh
methinks maybe not so much Oh Marlo
Linda Marla Linda Marla Linda where's
Marla Linda
is that Marla Linda what the [ __ ] was
that it was in a hurry whatever it was
okay I'll follow it what's the worst
that could happen
spawn just showing me the way out is
that a goat why is a goat in the vent I
don't know what's going on here but my
voice is starting to crack all that well
the screaming from the last episode man
the real like shocked screams it catch
me by surprise they like it's totally
like balls out if you know what I mean
and sometimes it can thrash up my voice
quite a bit so I'll try to be a little
bit softer with my voice maybe just a
little more gentle with it my vocal
coach said speaking like that is
actually a little bit but easier on your
voice to do so just a little bit higher
out of your normal register and then do
a register that's a bit easier on your
voice without straining the vocal cords
so this is the rest of the let's play
for everybody oh is this the way out I
bet not you okay that's good so far not
so bad why do I still need to collect
these damn fuses why is that important
oh that was close
actually I don't know are those eggs all
these are eggs aren't they ah I'm
walking on eggs I'm not walking on
sunshine
whoa
I didn't see that that was going to be
that way
crap boobie eye crap crap
I suck eggs okay here we go on dry land
once more so that wasn't a good sound
probably okay cool
anybody else want to jump out of me
please don't I know I request that a lot
but don't don't for once just don't okay
who else is here
oh boy a big hole in the ground it's
probably reassuring I'll just try to
stay away from that you don't mind is
that where the eggs were hopefully I
wonder if those were eggs I mean these
supposedly come from moon rocks so I can
only assume that the moon rocks have
moon eggs damn it we go
also the sensitivities again slightly
different than what it was before a
little more on this front okay so oh I
do got a jump down Yeah right fine
whatever huh oh crap oh crap this is a
horrible error hi ah okay what do I do
oh [ __ ] what do we do whoa goo goo goo
oh crap is a dead end isn't it poopy
poopy poopy in my pants ha poopy uh
you're gross
yeah little baby moon wings
- what do we do where am I supposed to
go what am I supposed to do
I'm not I'm not able to combat them am i
what god damn it what am i [ __ ]
supposed to do alright um dad I didn't
know where I was supposed to go okay
maybe I wasn't supposed to go through
there maybe it's all big line okay over
here okay okay follow the bright lights
obviously don't keep going on the
obviously blocked up path fighting moon
aliens and go the correct way okay I go
hello oh you're so comforting with your
squeals
we're like lucky I'm getting out of here
you all gonna shut up forever all good
is this a way out please tell me yes
come on baby come on no more ere we go
okay this looks good looks like it might
be almost out of here so I might be
almost free or maybe I just win the lair
of the biggest one yet hmm I don't know
I'm not sticking around to find out I'm
not stupid enough to sit around and wait
for the other one to eat my face off oh
come on
why do we need more fuses I don't know
any more fuses I don't know why why do I
need more oh boy what do I do
what do I do hello okay let me stop to
read for a little bit okay as of
yesterday several members of the team
have reported what sound to be horrific
hallucinations visions are consistent
across the board mentioning the name of
the watcher accompanied by horrendous
sites of extraterrestrial speed
practices one team member in particular
has drawn into a state of shock
seemingly acting outside of his will
he's being observed and study for any
further anomalies in brain activity and
cognition great so they're taking over
my mind good to know okay well that was
a little weird I'll take it okay where
am I going now where am I going now why
can't I be done with this fresh hell
yeah a little bit of lag Oh Oh
okay okay am I free Oh am i free get to
the rub why how do I get to the roof
how do I get to the roof oh come on
don't tell me this is just a stupid
taste of freedom thing I'm so close
poopy oh oh I can't go back oh good good
that means I need to move forward okay
so I just got to get to the roof
gotta get to the roof roof ah here we go
this lead seems to lead away from the
roof but I'll go to the roof I thought I
heard the thumpy thumpy of the
Slenderman
okay little weird bizarre know why I'm
in the woods now okay here we go oh I
thought that was a thing moving towards
me who's just zappy zaps okay here we go
really got a goodie goodie goodie going
Oh
Wow what-what-what-what I'm alive the
hell happened what the hell is that I
don't know what just happened but I
can't see too good anymore what what the
hell okay all right then well okay thank
you oh thank you just so happen to be
able to climb this one vent okay gotcha
cool
all righty then how about this one -
goody goody goody goody goody yep
all right so what awaits me up here more
moon aliens more bad stuff oh hi
locked you say well I don't think I want
to go in there anyway because there
seems to be monsters on the other side
but maybe just maybe oh my god it's
another puzzle there we go got it okay
cool cool another puzzle solved by my
giant brain so why am I going back in
why why would I be going back in for
what reason for what reason at all what
I need to go back in well but here I am
okay I was outside I could have run for
it I could have climbed one fence
oh I'm such a dingus why me in here I
don't know oh why do I keep climbing in
vents I obviously don't need to go into
I don't know then again this did seem
like the way he wanted me to go so not
really my fault
what if you go
oh that looks good I'll go towards that
oh okay what the hell is this what is
this
I do
what's really gone oh okay I guess
that's the end of job one I didn't know
this was a chapter-by-chapter thing okay
so that was that I am still alive
whatever her name was she's such a good
friend I barely remember her name okay
so I need to give my voice a little bit
of a rest now but I really hope you
enjoyed quadrant it was actually a very
very good game surprisingly good it is
available on Steam but the only thing is
I don't know if it's worth the $12 a
paid for it
however the $12 goes towards every
chapter down the road is there mate so
there's like an initial funding not
quite early access type thing but either
way let me know what you think of this
game in the description below in the
comments down below and let me know if
there's other horror games that you want
me to play sorry my voice kind of went
out towards the end of this but hey
puberty and all that thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye